hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
gilles verdez zanesi
[Applaudissements]
isabelle morini-bosc avec thierry bon
allez
[Musique]
on dirait qu'on est dans les bronzés les
doigts gars qu'on n'a pas d'avenir avec
la bouteille la bataille de la savoie
taxes et vos mariages a toujours le vote
tronqué mode tante qui vont danser un
moment et tout le monde est gêné et ont
cessé d'être dans l'ambiance soyez bien
c'est exactement ça allah allah je les
vois les deux mais la tristesse du
lancement pas fou et l hôtel et bonne
chose alors on va faire un autre couple
dernier couple improbable on va faire
enora malagré avec jean luc lhemanne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lots à la peau et lui mais il ferait pas
ça cathala j'ai fait j'ai fait un petit